abone ol
Herkese
merhabalar bu duyulabilir ve görülebilir
olduğunu düşünüyorum şu anda
öncelikle bu güzel davetleri için tebrik
yüzlü şekilde Çok teşekkür ediyorum ben
şimdi sizlerle hep beraber bir senaryo
kurgulayarak başlayacağız bu kurgu
sırasında da olaylar nasıl gelişir bir
sonraki adımda Ne olur kafanızda
canlandırdığınız rica edeceğim
Sen arıyoruz Bilim insanlarının
dünyamızı yok edecek Bir tehlike
keşfetmesi ile başlıyor bunu isterseniz
biraz Sony kolay hastalık salgın veya
felaket diyebilirsiniz ama her ihtimalde
Dünyamız altı ay içerisinde yok olacak
ve insanlık tamamen ortadan kaybolacak
bu durumu fark eden bilim insanlarımız
ise Tabii ki dünyamızı yok oluşun
eşinden Kurtarmak isteyenler değilim
Peki bu bir sorunla karşı karşıya olan
bilim insanları
81 yakın büyük ailemizin evinikur Allah
için ne yapmalı kime gitmeli ne yapar
nereye başvurmalı Sizce
gerekli adımları atması gereken en
yetkili karar mekanizmaları ile yani
devletlerle dünya liderleriyle görüşmek
karar verirsem hiçbiriniz anlarımız
hemen yetkili mercilerle tüm önlemlerin
alınması ve çalışmaların başlatılması
gerektiği hususunda görüşmek isterdim
bir
hemen bu noktada bir düşünelim bu
görüşmeyi ayarlamak için bile çok uzun
Bürokratik süreçlerden geçmek zorunda
kalabilirler değil mi aylarca Belki de
yanıt almaya bilirler görüşme
taleplerini
diyelim ki bu süreçte bir şekilde aşıldı
gerekli konuşmalarda yapıldı Sizce
görüşme gerçekleştiğinde bile ne kadar
ciddiye alınır Sonuçta Dünyamız Aslında
yok oluyor Bundan daha önemli ne
olabilir Şu an diyoruz hepimiz şu anda
bütün problemlerin aslında bir kenara
bırakıp Global bir şekilde tüm
önlemlerin alınması gerekiyor tüm
adımların başlatılması gerekiyor Şu an
bu ve hiçbir önemi yok Herhangi bir
dünya sorunu tamamen bu sonra kanalize
olmalı Şanlı Bence videomuzun düşündü
şey budur
Bu Peki dünyanın yok olma tehlikesini
bir kenara bırakalım şu anda günümüzde
Aslında yaşadığımız bireysel ve kitlesel
sorunlarla Biz bir şekilde devletlerimiz
de dünya liderleri ile iletişimde ilmek
farketmez sekte haklarımızı savunmak
için ekonomik sıkıntılarını gidermek
eğitim sağlamak vergilerinizi ödemek iş
bulmak için yaşadığınız ortamdaki
sorunları bildirmek için mesela sürekli
devletlerimiz yöneticilerimize Biz
iletişim halindeyiz en basitinden
diyemeyeceğim yaşadığımız muhitten
müddet temizlikten şikayetçiyiz Bu
sorunun çözümü için belediyelere başvuru
değil bunun gibi küçük veya büyük
hepimizin kendi kan ısınınca bir şekilde
biz devletlerle sürekli iletişim
halindeyiz Peki Sizler birer dünya
vatandaşı olarak ve bu sorunlarınıza
yeterince ilgilendirdiğini
düşünüyorsunuz
maalesef dünyanın her noktasında Her
insan yaşadıkları problemlerin çözümü
için gerekli adımların atılmasından
bulandırır dünyanın her köşesinde Ya
insanlar hala etnik kökenlerin den
dolayı yargılanıyorlar çocuklar açlıkla
boğuşuyor savaşlar binlerce hayat yok
etmeye devam ediyor gençler işsizlik
problemleriyle baş başa var ve Maalesef
bu gibi insanlığın birçok problemi hala
göz ardı ediliyor
bu kendinize sorun mesela tam şu anda
dünya liderleri tarafından
sorunlarımızın önemsendiğini
düşünüyorsunuz yoksa önemsiz çıkarlar
ürünü nasıl görevler Ak satılıyor
Biraz önce uyguladığımız bu senaryoda
Aslında yakın zamanlarda beyazperdede
doldu Kaplan yukarı bakma içine düştüğü
bu yaralandı Ben filmden birazcık
alıntılar yapmak istedim Çünkü beni bu
konuda çok etkilemişti filmi izleyenler
vardır bu yanımızda izlemeyenler de
kesinlikle tavsiye ediyorum çok detaya
girmeden film özetleyecek olursam
dünyamıza çarpacak olan bir göktaşı
bulan iki üniversite görevlisi devlet
tarafından göz ardı ediyorlar
problemleri defalarca kez belirtmeme
rağmen ilk başta kesinlikle ciddiye
alınmıyor lar Daha sonra da dünyanın yok
olacağı problemi siyasi bir Propaganda
olarak kullanılıyor filmde genel olarak
konusu bu ve çok güzel bir eleştiri
firmasında şu anda yayınlandı platformda
dünya çapında büyük bilgileri ilgiyle
karşılanan dolgu kapı ne kadar etkili
birleştiren yapımı olduğu konusunda
birçok yorum yapıldı Ama spesifik olarak
bazı bilim insanları kurgunun onların
günlük yaşamlarından farksız olduğunu
belirttiler ve tahmin edin bu bilim
insanları hangi alanda çalışma
yapıyorlar
bari iklim Turizm
gibi birçok alanda da uyarlanabilir
aslında bu ele bu Fakat bu filmin iklim
krizi alegorisi oldu aslında çok çok
açık yani orada göktaşı aslında şu an
bizim yaşadığımız iklim krizi ile ilgili
ipi sembolize ediyor ve maalesef
tepkisizliği mizi karar mekanizmalarının
bu konuda hala gerekli adımları atmaması
ile ilgili Belki de abartılı bir biçimde
bu durumu eleştiriyor Mesela bu konuda
iklim bilimci ve yazar da pikampüs
guardian'da ki bir yazısında şöyle diyor
toplumun iklim yıkımı karşısındaki
korkutucu tepkisizliği hakkında şimdiye
kadar gördüğüm en isabetli film
Biz Uzmanlar aktivistler gipro maçlar ve
birçok bu alanda bilgili kişi gibi
gençler olarak da iklim krizi dur demek
için bas bas bağırıyoruz bir zamandır
yani sadece filmlerde gördüğümüz ya da
simgesel olarak
bizlere anlatılmaya çalışan bir şey
değil biz bu alanda çalışmalar yapıyoruz
Özellikle de Genç nesil bizim
bu konuda fazlasıyla aktif Çünkü
bilincimiz de artıyor ve asıl
istediğimiz aslında hak ettiğimiz
geleceğe sahip
olabilmektir Bu durumun ciddiyetini
şöyle düşünebiliriz dizgesel Aslında en
temel hakkımız olan yaşam için mücadele
veriyoruz Bir noktada Çünkü bu şekilde
dünyamıza çalışmaya devam edersek
hayatından mahrum kalacak olanlarda
bugünün gençleri olacak olarak gelecekte
biz olacağız ve maalesef problemlerin
sorumlusu bizim Neslimiz olmamasına
rağmen sonuçlarına katlanmak durumunda
Dizler Düşeceğiz Peki Kral acılarımız
olan devletlerin en büyük yükümlülükleri
Aslında vatandaşların can güvenliğini ve
yaşam hakkını sağlamak değilmiş Aynen
öyledir vatandaşı olmayan bir devlet
nedir Sonuçları
vatandaşların yaşam hakkının sağlanması
birinci önceliktir
bizim iklim aktivisti gençler olarak da
en büyük isteğimiz tamam bu iklim
adaleti kim Adalet Aslında çok değişik
bir kavram değil mi yani İlk başta insan
düşünüyor iklimin adaletten Ne gibi bir
ilgisi olabilir arasındaki bağlantıyı
bir şekilde anlayamıyor insan
Sonuç olarak Evet belli sonuçlarla karşı
karşıya kalıyoruz küreselisinma
seviyeleri gittikçe artıyor Biz de
bunları Sonuç olarak yaşamaya başladık
Yazın çok fazla dünyanın heryerinde
yangınlar görüyoruz sel felaketleri veya
ekstrem hava koşulları etkilerin hepimiz
yaşıyoruz ve iklim Turizm bilet sonucu
olduğunun farkındayız ama iklim adaleti
gerçekten değişik bir kavram şu şekilde
çok güzel özetle bileceğim inanıyorum
Aslında benim gibi bir öğrencinin karbon
ayakizi yılda 3000-4000 kilogram
kaybolacaksın karbon ayakizi de aslında
bizim havaya salgıladığımız
karbondioksit miktarı en kapsamlı
açıklaması
o ve ben
hepimiz gibi buradaki öğrenciler gibi ya
da
bu normal bir vatandaş gibi yılda
3000-4000 kilogram karbondioksit
sallıyorum havaya atmosfere Aslında çok
büyük bir rakam gibi geliyor 3000-4000
kilogram
bakın geçtiğimiz yıl kısma gitmem bir
Silopi iklim Zirvesi gerçekleşti
Birleşmiş Milletler altında gerçekleşen
bu zirveye da dünyanın her yerinden
birçok devletten yetkililer devlet
adamları dünya liderleri katıldı
ve bu liderlerin birçoğu Klas kova bu
Zirve için
özel jetler ile gittiler Ben neredeyse
hepsi her biri bu hiçbir özel J tuşuyla
yaklaşık 10 üç buçuk ton karbondioksit
salınımına sebep oldular
bu işte iklim adaletsizliği tam olarak
Aslı bu
iklim krizi için büyük adımlar atılması
ülkeler tarafından sözler verilmesi
geleceğimizin güvence altına alınması
için yapılıyordu Fakat burada kararları
veren otoriteler bile bu zirveye gitmek
için 13 buçuk ton karbondioksit salınımı
sebep oldular Tekbir uçuşuyor Biz
gençler olarak her birimiz yılda bu
Maximum 4000 kilogram karbondioksit
sağlıyoruz
aynı şekilde bunu su krizinden de
örnekle biliriz endüstrileşmiş
kuruluşların sanayilerin harcadığı su
miktarıyla yine biz gençlerin
harcamasına bakacak olursak Bizimki
onların kimin yanında bir damla kalıyor
Fakat bu israf sebebiyle gelecekte günde
25 litre su ile yaşamak zorunda kalacak
olanlarda maalesef Biz gençleriz günde
25 litre Aslında ilk başta kulağa Çok
yeterli geliyor bu fakat yediğimiz
yemekten yediğimiz giysilere
kullandığımız kurye he bu ne kadar
Aslında her şey bizim sol ayak izimizi
belirliyor ve Ortalama bir insan
yaklaşık binde 3bin litre su kullanıyor
burada ilk başta düşünüyoruz 2 litre
içme suyu içiyoruz Evet peki musluklar
vesaire ama 3000l çok
kafa patlatıcı bırakamazsın ve 25 lira
ile karşılaştığımız zaman yaşamak
neredeyse imkansız bir hale gelecek
diyebiliriz
kim adaletsizliği konusunda da bu
sebeple jenerasyonunun gösterdiği çaba
çok çok önemli çünkü biz gerçekten
burada bir yaşam mücadelesi veriyoruz
aslında gerek iklim grevleriyle
organizasyonlarla Akdeniz'e Biz
göstermeye çalışıyoruz karar alıcılar
alıp taleplerimiz iletiyoruz ama ne
kadar ulaşacak ta bizim sesimiz hala
duymuyor
Biz gençler olarak konuda Elimizden
geleni yapmaya Aslında hazırız ben buna
can-ı gönülden demeyelim daha bu hafta
mesela Kendi okulunda bir Sürdürülebilir
çevreci yaşam proje yaptım ve gönüllülük
için proje tanıtımında akşam akşam
larımız ve özellikle de ortaokul çağında
aslında küçük çocuk diyebileceğimiz
jenerasyon uzun bireylerinin iklim krizi
için bireysel adımlar atmak için bile o
kadar istekli olduğunu gözlemledim
orada kesinlikle emin oldum Biz aslında
bu konuda adım adım atmak isteyen
jenerasyonu sadece duyulmaya ve bu
süreçlerde dahil olmaya ihtiyacımız var
iklim bir evlerimize dediğim gibi
etkinliklerle basın açıklamalarımız da
sürekli bunları söylüyoruz aynı benim şu
anda bu konuşmada yaptığım gibi ama
Bizler artık karar mekanizmaları
tarafından dinlenmekle kalmayıp bu
süreçlerde yer verilmeyi taleplerimizin
ciddiye alınması ve uygulamaya geçmeleri
gereken bir döneme çoktan geç Çünkü
dediğim gibi gelecekte bütün bunlarla
karşılaşacak olan bütün
bu dünyayı çok Belki de farklı bir yöne
çekecek olan sonuçlarla başa çıkması
gerekecek olanlar bizim neslimize
maalesef biz karar süreçlerine dahil
edilmiyor ve
sebep olmadığınız problemlerin
sorumluluğunu almak Kesinlikle aslında
bize düşen bir durum değil Ben şu anda
bu konuşmada bu kadar maalesef negatif
konuşuyor olmak değil de belki de şunu
demeyi çok daha isterdim beni climat
istedim
bu konuşmaları Yaptım Yaptım ve bir
şekilde ben karar alma mekanizmaları
tarafından süreçlere dahil edildim ve
gençlerin sesi olarak
bu iklim krizi ile ilgili mücadelede
adımlarda gençlerin isteklerini dile
getirdim biz bu şekilde iklim prizini
yenmeye doğru çok büyük adımlar atıyoruz
benim kesinlikle gelecekte kullanmak
istediğim cümle budur
Bu Wifi bu mesela son raporuna göre şu
an Durdurulamaz sonun tam olarak
eşiğindeyiz yani ya Çok iyi bir yere
doğru gideceğiz ya da uçurumdan atlama
ya hazırlanacağız bu şekilde küresel
ısınma seviyesi günümüz itibariyle 1,0
dokuz derece biz onu yuvarlayalım 1,1
derecede yerim bizim limitimiz bir buçuk
derece ama biz bu limiti açmakla
kalmayıp şu an 2,7 derecelere doğru çok
büyük bir hızla gidiyoruz dünyacı olarak
gerekli adımlar atılmadığı sürece de
zaten bu sıcaklık seviyelerine maalesef
ulaşacağız dik duruyor
Can Bu çok tehlikeli eşikten dönmek için
büyük adımları atmak isteyen ama
atamayan atmasına izin verilmeyen nesil
olarak uçurumdan düşme mize göz
yumulması Biz kabul etmiyoruz Bu yüzden
iklim Adalet sağlanana kadar da
geleceğimiz için mücadele etmeye devam
edeceğiz iklim krizi bir insan o
problemidir iklim krizi iklim adaleti
bir insan hakkıdır O yüzden artık
gençlerin bu konuda söz sahibi
olmasının bir zorunluluk olduğunu
tekrardan belirtiyorum Çok teşekkür
ederim